[Musik]
sie warten über 100 Journalisten haben
sich
akkreditiert Sarah wadenknecht kommt als
letzte in den Saal zusammen mit rund 400
Delegierten will sie heute den
Grundstein einer neuen Volkspartei legen
auch Ehemann oscar lafontain ist dabei
da ist etwas am kippen in unserer
Gesellschaft es gibt so viele Probleme
so viel Unsicherheit aber auch so viel
Empörung und Wut mündet der Umbruch in
einen Aufbruch oder in die Katastrophe
alles ist möglich
ehrenamtliche der Partei sind seit
Wochen unterwegs um Landesverbände zu
gründen für Sachsen und micklenburg
vorpomn ist Sabine Zimmermann zuständig
sag mal wie bist du auf BSW gekommen ich
bin Mutter von drei Kindern so wie es in
unserem Land aktuell ist so kann es
nicht weitergehen ich habe viele in
meinem persönlichen Umfeld die seit
Jahren gar nicht wählen weil sie sagen
es bringt ja sowieso
nicht das ist glaube ich auch ein ein
großes Problem was wir hier in
Deutschland haben die Unglaubwürdigkeit
der Politik denn die Menschen glauben
niemand mehr eigentlich hat Sabine
Zimmermann hier in Zwickau einen Termin
im Rathaus das heute davor Bauern und
Handwerker demonstrieren wusste sie
nicht auf Parteien und Politik ist hier
keiner gut zu sprechen wir wollen gar
keine
hab der kitapatz müsste eigentlich
umsonst sein
Schulessen die Renten müssen Gesicher
sein wenn ich einkaufen gehe da möchte
ich für 150 € vollen einkaufskurb haben
und kein halben Sabine Zimmermann ist
Gewerkschafterin für die Linke sah sie
16 Jahre im
Bundestag ihr lasst euch nicht alles
gefallen und das ist wichtig doch ihre
Partei wurde der gelernten
baustoffingenieurin immer
fremder kümmern sich um Gendern die
kümmern sich um die klimakleber aber sie
kümmern sich halt nicht um die
wirklichen Probleme die die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger haben vier Mitglieder des
zwiekauer Stadtrats sind deshalb aus der
linken aus und in die wagenknechtpartei
eingetreten die Linken Lifestyle Themen
hätte doch keiner mehr verstanden ich
finde das ist einfach übertrieben worden
und das hat die Bevölkerung auch nicht
mehr wahrgenommen hat abgeschalten
hatest hat gedacht die die sind verrückt
vor allen Dingen die
Migrationspolitik kann ja nicht so
weitergehen bei uns in der Orts mir habe
ich Leute genossen dabei gehabt mit 83
84 Jahren mit 60 Jahre parteizuchigkeit
die haben die Linke verlassen und kommen
zu
uns vor dem Parteitag demonstriert die
Antifa Querfront seit das rechts offen
und gefährlich ihr kriegt kein Fuß auf
die Straße in
Berlin dieich
mensverachungindük teilweise führen das
Werben für Frieden rechts die
Verteidigung der Bauernhöfe rechts die
Kritik an Schulschließungen und
Konformitätsdruck in der coronazeit
rechts die Forderung nach Begrenzung der
Zuwanderung und die Sorge vor
islamistischen Parallelgesellschaften
rechts ich glaube der erste Fehler wäre
das bündniswagenkncht und die AFD jetzt
einfach in einen Topf zu werfen und zu
sagen das sind alles populistische oder
extremistische Parteien das wäre wieder
genau sozusagen dieses vorschnelle im
was was ich glaube was nicht nicht gut
wäre sondern was uns bei der AFD was wir
da versäumt haben was Politik aber
sicherlich auch Gesellschaft auch Medien
in Teilen versäumt haben war wirklich
eine inhaltliche
Auseinandersetzung auf genau die freut
sich Thomas Geisel er ist Politprofi war
Oberbürgermeister von Düsseldorf und SPD
Genosse hier das ist meine jüngste
Urkunde 40 Jahre Treue Mitarbeit bei der
uns gesellschaftlichen Ziele doch nach
40 Jahren wollte er nicht mehr bei ihm
war der Parteiaustritt auch Endpunkt
eines langen
entfremdungsprozesses der SPD Ehrennadel
zum Trotz das ist einmal das Thema
Legalisierung von Cannabis die
Selbstbestimmung der sexuellen Identität
wenn der Eindruck entsteht das sind die
Kernprojekte die herzensprojekte einer
sozialdemokratisch geführten Regierung
dann stimmt irgendwas nicht seine
Tochter hilft mit Unterstützer für den
wahlkamp
is Spitzenkandidat des BSW für die
Europawahl ist richtig gut ist ein super
netter politisch will er zurück in die
alte
Bundesrepublik Helmut Schmidt warb mit
weiterarbeiten am Modell Deutschland
also dass wir sagen wir verwirklichen
wieder die Prinzipien die die
Bundesrepublik stark gemacht die die
Bundesrepublik durchaus zu einem Land
gemacht das von seinen Nachbarn
bewundert wurde oder jedenfalls
geschätzt wurde was soll daran so
schlimm sein die Bundesrepublik ist ein
mit dem Slogan Wohlstand für alle
gestartet jeder der sich anstrengt
sollte Aufstiegschancen und die Aussicht
auf ein gutes Leben haben diese
Aufstiegschancen die gibt es doch fast
gar nicht mehr genauso wenig wie die
alte Bundesrepublik so Politologe FK sie
seoll allein wegen der Globalisierung
für immer dahin was vermisst wird und
was als Mangel erlebt wird ist a eine
gewisse Stabilität für die die Bonner
Republik stand B
[Musik]
ein demokratischer Kapitalismus also wo
Demokratie und kapitalistische
Profitmacherei Ausbeutung irgendwie so
zusammengeht als eine kompromissformel
und C
auch eine ich würde sagen
außenpolitische
Zurückhaltung eine Parteijugend gibt es
bisher nicht an der Spitze zwar eine
Frau doch der Rest ist ziemlich männlich
und alt aber noch ist die Partei ja erst
ein paar Wochen alt unsere Welt ist
nicht in Ordnung und deswegen sagen wir
Nein zu Krieg und Nein zu Waffenexporten
in Kriegsgebiete das muss gestoppt
werden es ist interessant offensichtlich
die Partei Versen wird so kann man nach
dem Tag heute haben diese Erzählung also
wir sind die neue Friedenspartei in den
Vordergrund zu stellen und damit auch
Abgrenzung zu betreiben zu den beiden
Parteien die vielleicht früher als
friedensparteien wahrgenommen werden
würden nämlich einerseits die SPD in der
Tradition natürlich auch von Willi Brand
etwa aber auch natürlich die Grünen die
ja ursprünglich auch aus der
Friedensbewegung herausentstanden sind
das könnte stimmen bringen denn so
mehrheitlich wie der Bundestag Waffen
befürwortet tut es die Bevölkerung nicht
mehr es wird den Parteienwettbewerb
verändern es wird die
Zusammensetzung der Landesparlamente
ändern es wird die öffentliche Debatte
verändern also welche
Themen werden diskutiert also gerätt
einiges in
Bewegung die anderen Parteien werden mit
Sarah Wagenknecht politisch umgehen
müssen eine Herausforderung denn die
bekannten Etiketten passen hier nicht
mehr